[Music]
location under
Charter 373
Commander Mills my ship was hit by an
undocumented asteroid
[Music]
transporting 35 passengers
on a long-range exploratory mission
[Music]
send help
we've crash landed on an Uncharted
Celestial body
[Music]
I've located One Survivor
a giant
the atmosphere is breathable
something alien out there
you need to be quiet and move
you and I are gonna get home oh family
ready
[Applause]
right
now
I'm gonna tell you something
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
meta girl fell in love that girl died
but then she came back
came back a totaled dick oh please
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
didn't want to make things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends
incinerate them
they're always searching for a family
until we found each other
are you ready
for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
and beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
just never noticed how black your eyes
were they were replaced by my father as
a method of torture he he picked a
pretty set
it's breathtaking
when you see sand here imagine water if
you dive in you can't reach the bottom
you dive in yes it's cold swimming I
don't I don't believe you
in the shadows of arrakis lie many
secrets
the darkest of them all may remain
the end of House of treaties no father
didn't believe in Revenge
what if Paula treaties were still alive
have you ever had a dream about your
first ride
laughs
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Jonas we need your help
we're detecting increased aquatic
activity 25 000 feet deep in the trench
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
man whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface
this is a bad idea just a little bit
thank you
Jonas
we've got company
I've ever seen
biggest bag anyone's ever seen
everybody back into the station
three massive exit who knows what else
have escaped the breach
I just hope it goes better than last
time
what happened last time
I wanna know
[Applause]
you've never seen this before they
hunted it back
we can relax this place is magproof when
Jonas was always afraid of this but I
was also thinking
[Music]
barracuda
we are a dwarf
we will annihilate everything
champions of this realm can do nothing
to stop us
you are very menacing I just want you to
know that
a lot has changed in the last few years
the wizard gave me superpowers
but then everybody got superpowers
all right here's the situation
the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt us
children is told the power of the Gods
from our father's call okay okay maybe I
should be writing all this down
your world will not survive this
you want these Powers come get them hey
Khaleesi
now we're here all right
we have one job to do save the world
finally
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I can't do this take my powers back you
gave them to me so you would take them
back right
I spit the Millennia
searching for worthy champion
exactly what must be done
Billy what are you doing I have to do
this we end this now yeah
we do
start in front of
[Music]
them
now we're here
but it looks like this is home for the
night
goddamn wind
Clarence
local officials have declared a
Statewide emergency as these
unprecedented storms continue to rain
sure it's not a Bus full of prisoners
heading our way got caught in the storm
we need a place to hunker down until
it's safe watch on your best behavior
while we're here let's get a few things
straight you're in my house now I will
not hesitate to shoot you if I have to
if y'all don't think this is cruel and
unusual right here
they got in your damn police station
storm brought him in could be infested
with them by now if you want to survive
the night we're gonna have to find a way
to get along keep an eye on him that's a
Bonafide cop kill it right there
we're all gonna get eaten alive
oh
[Music]
you got one shot Sheriff
I hear the taste like chicken
[Music]
for centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden
on Earth
the darkness has found us again
prime
this is about the fate of all living
things
Unicron is coming
thank you
back up Oh I thought we were boys
not a human here I'm nobody I ain't even
seen nothing I'm not even seeing
anything right now
foreign
[Music]
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
everything you cared for
will be consumed
maybe there's another way to save our
home
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
thank you
[Music]
yo Noah Take the Wheel
boys where have you been
we're just running errands that's it
[__] him out of it
yeah you rented us out hey don't use
that word that way I mean sorry Dad
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted what would you guys do go
to high school maybe get a girlfriend
can you imagine that not likely
[Music]
team I want to know everything about you
our dad is definitely not a giant rat
that makes me feel like he's a rap
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we take out
Superfly and then everyone will think
we're cool
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
that's a little tortoises huh I can't
believe there are other mutants you want
to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
peoples they got to go okay um sort of a
twist
we can't stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dog
my son Michelangelo you have hearts
Donatello you have wisdom Raphael you
have bravery and Leonardo honor
talk I dream about fighting every night
you've got a rage it's not a problem
the Demeter on Charter from Romania to
London
shipping private crates
content unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
this year's comments he's a doctor
you dress like a learned man University
of Cambridge I know my way around the
boat our Charter has agreed to pay a
bonus for timely arrival in London
let me show you the ship this here is
huckleberry
we don't come with like this to give the
US clear
[Applause]
something read about the animals
all the livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship everywhere
evil isn't work
[Music]
powerful evil
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
see the size of that bloody thing
[Music]
he is on this ship which means that we
will never leave it the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
you're an interesting man
Scotland
you're an Avenger
[Music]
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time like me
we could help each other with that
who are you I'm the man who can give you
the one thing you want
what's that
time
I can rewrite existence
and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much
[Music]
give us a second chance
let me make this easy for you
he will bring me what I need
or everything you call a life will end
is all my fault
you may not want her to watch this we
had a deal
you thought you could win
I don't have to win
we both just have to lose
[Music]
I'm sorry Cassie
oh
[Music]
what
what your mother never told you you were
royalty the women in our family had the
mighty power to turn into giant Kraken
what now movie you're a prince
princess
okay Ruby have it completely totally
ordinary day you got this
[Music]
I feel like a freak ow I just want to be
Ruby Gilman normal teenager oh so
where's the fun in that you have powers
beyond your imagination
are the protector of all the oceans
creatures it's up to you to stop the
evil mermaids but people love mermaids
of course they do people are stupid
show me how to use my power are you
ready
let's see what you're capable of
body armor laser eye
almost
it's time to go big
still on for a tutoring session later
right oh
anything for my algebra you do what no I
mean bro
algebra like you're my brother you're my
math brother
you know I think I like the first one
better
I'll ever
Captain Rambo
what the hell are you doing
entering the jump Point perimeter
I'm gonna get you some readings Fury
hello Monica hello
[Music]
is this an Avengers
where's Captain Rambo
[Music]
what the hell now
hi we're looking for a malecon
[Applause]
okay so our powers are entangled I can
manipulate light energy and you I could
totally show you
hi where's our doctor wherever you were
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
we're a team oh no no no we're not we're
not a team
[Music]
foreign
okay chop it off chop it off let's do it
oh we got him now
you know what I'm thinking they're
probably sharper stairs somewhere else
he helped the wrong person steal the
wrong thing and unleash the greatest
evil the world has ever known
the red Wizards created an army of the
undead
sounds lovely quite the opposite I know
I was being ironic I find irony as a
blazer because he who wields it most
especially you're not a lot of fun are
you how are we gonna pull this off we're
gonna need a team
you need
the orifice
I'll go lost
I don't mind that
she missed
no that's not good
I'm just sick of failing we could die
there's worse things than dying
I lost everything that ever mattered to
me and if we quit now that's for nothing
I don't want to see you die which is why
I'm Gonna Leave the Room
oh
the bridge is protected by an ancient
trap we must not trigger the mechanism
I may have triggered the mechanism
so
sorry
foreign
[Music]